hey
he tried to get me to relapse right he
said i want you to taste wine oh wow
yeah
are you serious yeah he was like he was
like that's what you tasted i just he
said i just want you i just want you to
you know why drink wine drinkers do that
i want you to understand why you just
stop drinking it so it can't be that
good that's what i'm saying
he goes i i just want you here's what
here's what i just said you know what i
don't think he knows what kind of
alcohol it is i i don't you just thought
he just did like yeah i had a real
problem sorry i think he's like
don't don't dip your your toe in that
i'm sitting here like
when you're dealing with the attic dude
you can't here's what i do now that i
don't drink anymore which is i'll have a
beer sometimes and i do have a beer you
don't look like a beer guys family not
really my family is all drinking and
eating dessert and oh bro i get so much
pleasure saying judging no and i go no
then you feel better i sip my water and
i watch them eat dessert and and drink
alcohol and i just sit there like that
and then they go you don't want anything
i go no and you feel you feel like
you're better you have that strength
like i'm better i perch yeah it's fun
though you know sure
i'm not hey i have a lot of fun even
though i don't drink not as much fun as
the rest of us
have a good time i have a good time have
a good time i do have a good time some
guys don't need to be drunk though at
that time but for me i think it was just
the way i was introduced to alcohol like
if i wasn't introduced to it in such a
crazy way yeah then i'd probably be okay
because i mean like what you know people
there's people that yeah they drink
their wine with their dinner it's just
like kind of like a thing you have your
you have wine with your dinner like you
have a beer with your food and [ __ ]
that's not how i was introduced to
alcohol you know well if you have that
relationship with alcohol it's just
you don't need it you don't yeah there's
no i don't need it i'm doing i'm doing
fine without it i'm listening to brian
but literally he was like he didn't know
he doesn't know
i was like we'll do a taste
my last reason
i literally if i had a sip black sabbath
if i had a sip literally i think i'd
yeah i'd probably be worse than i was
i've seen i've seen
and people say that like whenever you
know like that's how people get guy like
with like when when people overdose
stuff like people that have been off it
for so long they'll try to take the the
dose of the same dose the same dose
there's an actor i'll try to drink the
same way no there's an actor i know i
won't mention his name but he had a
problem with alcohol uh-huh
no i won't go into it but he had he had
a problem with that
and nope keep going but but i watched
and i was like and i remember because i
know i was like i don't what what do you
mean i don't know what that is a problem
with alcohol well
i was drinking some wine and he came in
and it was an expensive bottle of wine
and pulled the bottle off my table
drank that and then poured and grabbed
another bottle poured the glass drank
that and
he threw the glass on the ground took
off his shirt and ran down sunset avenue
and then the rest is history so
i had never seen that level of insanity
things didn't work
they can't control it like there's no
they don't have that they'll drink all
the wine they drink all the wine until
they fall down all the ones get hit by
them
you guys ever take those shots uh that
was called like the the three horsemen
or sorry four horse horsemen you ever
hear that one uh-uh it's like jack jim
no uh i don't know know you guys didn't
get down like that see that's no too old
for that yeah i never i never got down
with getting black out drunk no not my
thing no no now you guys think no so i'm
gonna actually no one else can relate to
me if you do that too
i'm gonna run the other
directions knuckleheads can why can't
why can't uh drink yeah yeah you drink
yeah you drink drink not that much i
like that i like to smoke more than i
like to drink but you you'll get
hammered oh yeah you should that's what
i'm saying you've come in hammered a few
times you're coming here hammered well
no not hammered but uh
but a little saucy
yeah
did you guys who won did i miss the
the who won the chin versus we didn't do
that yet oh they didn't do it yet
because they had chin chin saw what
happened to chappelle and was like i'm
good you got you got i got rocked he got
dealt with i got dealt those two little
chick monks over there yeah squirreled
down yeah went straight for the nuts yep
escorted big guys
at the knockout
nine seconds i can't remember because
you
yeah they want to do i was like all
right let's see what happens and i was
like good luck
good luck man he's short like a fire
hydrant those two little weasels there
dude yeah yeah did you see one like
brian
because brendan was cheering me on he
was like okay chappelle okay and then
all of a sudden i got lifted in the air
and i was like oh this is i make a call
you take my sprawl class you take my
sprawl workshop you got it
29.
29.99
29.99 brian will teach you how to spell
i'm not taking a sprawl class for these
pictures look at that great picture both
legs
off the ground so your legs never been
on the ground you should have you should
have been so wrong this is for sure
that's hard to spread that comment wins
they marcus
you don't have a chance
wait go to the video go to christian's
page or who do you what do you know
pretty high quality yeah your quality is
good
that's a good question but brian but
you'll see
and give me your pointers give me your
pointers
where did i [ __ ] up you could sprawl on
you could have sprawled on him it would
have been tough turn your hips
what do you mean by him they did a good
job they have mine
they have my legs good coordinated
effort it was good yeah but shortly
i was like chapelle lacy university of
louisville cheerleading yeah
now and then they didn't give a [ __ ]
yeah that's why you were a cheerleader
and didn't play football
it's a legit point as well no it's kind
of double wizard than me and just
throwing your hands
though you know no but no shut up yeah
don't make me laugh my lips are dry are
they chapped
i was in the drive with my pops playing
golf in in the in the mountains of utah
oh yeah did you do 18. up there um did i
send you the elk video no no please
don't well they're just like
a lot of hell we're friends
but we're friends you wouldn't do that
to your friend i wouldn't nothing drives
me more crazy someone's gonna be like
check out the view and greet
or look at the elf that are on the
[ __ ] track the green i have i've
googled dumb
google here
there is a heard about that'll just hang
out on the green and now
what are you going to do don't send me
the but don't you don't because it's
just hell but it's exciting notice
unless an elk stabbed your father in the
chest don't send me the video right i'm
right with you i know i'm saying you
want something exciting yeah you don't
want just [ __ ] a view of an elk oh
you posted it no no it's something else
this is me that looks beautiful though
show me how showing you how to golf yeah
i don't wear those shoes though huh come
on dude they're my tennis shoes don't be
don't be
wait those aren't traditional just a
couple whites playing tennis am i right
a couple of whites
just a couple privileged wife someone
said bro in their first brightest shoes
i've seen in
the 85 year old you look like a retired
teacher god damn it
god damn it mr sam
you look like that cool social studies
teacher i was like like rap yeah you're
like
you kids know where this is my swing is
flawless this is ludicrous with atl
oh look at that that was a nice hit
whatever are you pretty good at golf no
no you're like you play all you you can
you can you can play good at unless you
play all the time and also i don't care
you know what bothers me but golf here's
the other thing you hit the ball and
you're the people that are watching go
they'll start talking to the ball skip
skip bounce better take it keep going
go go go go
shut up shut up
i don't care i don't care to be good at
going if it's 18 holes it's there goes
your day oh yeah it's six hours it's so
long that [ __ ] long it's you started
two years for at least four if you're
well you can't start at two papa you
guys you'll start at 9 a.m so you at
least have some sort of a day left you
don't have a day you're and you're
dehydrated in the sun also i'll say this
any friend i have who's around my age
who's like oh you want a golf you don't
have [ __ ] going on
because i do i don't have a day where i
have eight hours to dedicate your ass
correct hitting that little white ball
i play golf i'm my kid yeah yeah i play
golf because i get to hang with the 81
year old that's mine and he enjoys it
what's what is it and we've we [ __ ] with
each other and it's great it's me and my
dad it's that long i don't know how much
longer that's a super chap though little
chat i didn't drink enough water usually
oh it's drying you tall though huh yeah
so you got to keep drinking water even
when you're not thirsty i didn't tell
you the story chappelle heard it
we'll kick off with this
i know usually we [ __ ] around stuff this
isn't a funny story in any family i
wanted to ask you yeah because i heard a
little something through the grapevine
but i don't know what happened
so that's why i called you to see if you
were i know and i was like i'll tell you
on the show yeah because i don't want to
keep repeating this story um
so on thursday night a little date night
i mean my fellow date night we were
gonna meet our friends at scopa yeah so
we're driving to the west side and we're
we're driving down there went off the
101 right by encino
and my girl goes oh holy [ __ ] babe slow
down slow down go watch she goes there's
an accident they look at that 18-wheeler
so the 18-wheeler is like like this like
the front knife like that and then it's
like this so it's cut off the two
nearest lanes we're like what the [ __ ]
so my guy would just go around so we're
going around and there's a car just
mangled and there's a seven-year-old a
six or seven because i have kids right
there's like a six or seven year old on
top of the car like this
like this yelling for help so i'm like
babe oh that's a [ __ ] kid and she's
like just keep going like no it's a it's
a kid and then he's pointing down i look
in there's two other kids in the car
so i pull up there's like debris
everywhere i pull up i get out i go i
told my girl i go do not get out of the
car stay here because because you know
my family chp and he says never pull
over an accident it's too dangerous
never ever people get [ __ ] up all the
time but i thought because the 18
wheeler was blocking the lanes we had
some protection
so i get out
and i'm i'm running towards the kids and
it's probably i don't i'm not we're not
close because i have to go past all the
debris and stuff because the car's
hitting debris is like flying everywhere
so i pulled pretty far up
so i'm running towards the the mangled
car
and i see a guy with no shoes on he's in
a wife beater like kind of out of shape
mexican running across the 101. i'm like
what the [ __ ]
i'm looking and then a dodge drago
probably going 60 miles an hour whack
hits him and i'm like what in the [ __ ]
is going on man and he's on the ground
like rolling like this i don't think i'm
like what in the [ __ ] man so i'm just
thinking about the kids
so i keep going and that 18-wheeler
where the car hit it hit the the gas
it hit the gas tank so 18-wheelers have
all the gas in the world so there's
a flow of gas this as thick as this room
fly flooding out so my shoes my jeans
are all covered with gas because i'm
running so the gas is sprayed so it
smells so much like gas oh my god this
isn't safe in my head i'm like [ __ ] i
have kids man i can't go out like this
but i'm thinking of those kids
that guy who got hit pops up and then
crosses the other lanes but as he pops
up i'll never he looks he like looks at
me and has this crazy look in his eyes
and i'm like what in the [ __ ] is up with
that man
i get to the car the car's all [ __ ]
mangled and there's one other guy there
who's on the scene maybe he's the truck
driver i'm not sure but me and him are
the first on the scene
and there's two kids and there's the oh
i'm gonna try this without crying
there's a bigger kid and he keeps going
i don't want to die i don't want to die
you're not gonna die buddy you're not
gonna die and i tell the guy i'm like
back up back up
so i grabbed the door and i'm trying to
[ __ ] but it's mangled from the crash
so it's like intertwined with the with
the car so i'm like back up i'm trying
to pull down i can't so i go we gotta
smash this window and get him through
the window so i break the window we
break some of the window out it's
already broke i'm not like [ __ ]
captain america so i i'm pulling all the
shattered glass and i take the kid
through so the big big kid he's like out
of shape like kid who kept going out i
don't want to die i want to die
this little brother uh who's probably
two and a half or three
i unbuckle him i get him out of the car
and i look at the other guy and i go
he's there anybody in the car and he
goes there's i think there's one other
person in the front
so i'm grabbing the kid and i go sorry
bob it's all right and then i look
and then the front is a uh
a lady who passed away
um brain matter everywhere blood
everywhere and the kid's going mom my
mama and i go
i go bubba look at me
look at me look at me look at me don't
look over there because he was so young
it would have completely [ __ ] him up
so i go look at me don't look over look
at me i look at there you go get a
blanket
cover his mom
and there's a lady walks up i don't know
where she came from
and i go take these two kids and run
that way run away from the car and she
goes well i think it's better to go that
way don't go that way because the mom's
there they can't see the mom go that way
and so i sprint back i sprint back to my
car
and my girls like she's all freaking out
stuff like that so i get in the car and
we're going i have blood on my shirt and
stuff like that
and so i was a little mad at myself for
you know putting my girl in that
situation then i have kids i'm like man
what the [ __ ] am i doing and so i was a
little mad
and then you know my father-in-law's chp
i call him and tell him i'm like you
know i was the first on the scene but i
didn't stick around because it's so
dangerous and you know hopefully i don't
get in trouble for it but if you need
any witnesses i saw it all and he was
okay we'll keep you posted they're gonna
need your uh
report the little kid that was on the
top of the car what happened he was fine
he came around okay and i kept telling
my dude you're a badass you're you're
such a badass dude you're so brave man
i said you're so brave dude you're such
a little badass man i'm so proud of you
i know you don't know me i'm so proud of
you dude because you're the reason i
stopped and i got your brothers i said
i'm so [ __ ] proud of you
so the lady took the kids
and then
you know uh get a call from uh the lapd
chp after that give them whatever
everything i saw
i said what the [ __ ] happened man
and they said that guy that you saw that
get hit by the car that morning woke up
told his kids we're all going to heaven
today
and he got on uh havenhurst uh to get on
the 101 went into traffic
and decided he was going to kill the
whole family and run into 18 wheeler and
so they the driver of the 18 wheeler
goes yeah i saw the car come in and i i
veered i was like what the [ __ ] i veered
right and he veered right i veered left
he veered left and he just ran into me
well that [ __ ] idiot that dad who
want to kill the whole family
obviously he didn't die and then um
the kids didn't die just just the the
mom died just the mom died
so i was like we gotta we we gotta do i
gotta do something i could i can't say i
can't sleep you can't sleep all i
remember that lady man like i've seen
movies and you know you think movies
until you [ __ ] see it man i can't get
on my head so i haven't been able to
sleep that's why dude your eyes are
ready
i said that to you i keep thinking about
kids keep thinking about the kids
and then um
a friend of mine sent me their gofundme
because i was like we gotta do something
help these kids like
so this is the mom so this is what on
the gofundme so they and this just for
the funeral cost they're trying to raise
30
000. they have 20 20 400 right now so it
says on thursday august 12th my niece
amy garcia who's 26 was killed in a
wrong way dr driving collision with the
big rig on the 101 freeway in encino she
leaves behind four beautiful children
all under the age of eight she was
loving karen mother unfort unfortunately
she was a victim of domestic violence
for many years and yesterday the
aggressor fulfilled his uh objective and
entered the freeway the wrong direction
intentionally killing my niece thank god
the children are fine but very
traumatized
we're asking for help for burial
expenses anything you can do to help us
will be greatly appreciated rest in
peace my dear amy you will be terribly
missed
so i reached out to the aunt because
i'll help pay for the funeral
i told her i'll help pay for the funeral
but i'm gonna help those kids out man
how do you help the kids out so i sent
her an email
uh oh and you know hopefully she gets
back to me on that i don't know what you
do like think think and i was talking
about an educational friend of somebody
i thought yeah something i was talking
about
yes
i saw everybody taught about it
he was like well one thing to make you
feel better
you got to feel like in that household
if the dad was that [ __ ] up yeah he
wanted to kill that entire family yes
and domestic abuse those kids are so
much better off without that dad i mean
their mom who knows what was going on
there but without that dad so hopefully
these kids because they weren't gonna
have a shot to get from the jump with
that shitty dad the question who raises
them now you know that's what i'm
getting at
he has an ant they have an ant who did
this hopefully grandma grandpa and maybe
help them out we'll figure out a way to
help them out with them
thing help them out like you know where
you can raise a lot of money with just
one show and we can get a lot of people
i can raise money for them yeah i can do
that and and then maybe just to help out
because that's four extra kids in a
household right so
you want to keep the kids together under
the same the gofundme i don't mind but
it's for the funeral cost you know 30
grand but it's like
you know that's one she's passed away
but it's like those kids are what we
should be raising money for yeah so
that's in some ways you can donate to
the gofundme there to hit hit their mark
and then hopefully i can figure out a
way to get a hold of this you did a good
thing dude yeah
you know man thank god you did it
because that you're not saying who was
it who said that if not if not you who
if not now when
sometimes you know that's a very apt
thing to ask yourself and i don't know
what what happened to those kids maybe
that that gasoline would have got to
them or the dad comes back or the dad
comes back or whatever and i wish i
would have known that i wish i would
have known that dad was such a piece of
[ __ ] i wish i would have known that was
going on yeah he'll be dealt with in his
own way that that guy's that guy's
got his own demons obviously and he's
a real piece of [ __ ] yeah but those kids
man
you know yeah
and you're right friend
you're right i i i'd like to think most
listeners of this show would have done
the same thing
well i think they would have been maybe
maybe just just if you could just
because if i always need help if i was
in the same position i would hope
somebody would [ __ ] stop yep yeah and
unfortunately a lot of times people
don't no you know and and because
everybody says the same thing don't get
involved but yeah i'm a believer and if
you see somebody who's in trouble like
that i'm a big believer in helping
people out you know because that's
exactly why my parents that way my
father was always that way i've seen my
father do things like that that were
similar when i was growing up and i i
believe in that man well imagine how i
mean who knows how long that kid was
just waving there before someone you
know
initially got not long because it just
happened it was god damn man what uh
what up that'll [ __ ] your that'll [ __ ]
your
whole
year up yeah yeah heavy
hopefully we can help them somehow yeah
without just paying for the funeral you
know that's a crazy story a good family
yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think i think that uh like
what you said is the silver lining is
that that monster no longer
that monster is no longer in their life
and never will be
you know
what a piece of [ __ ] man piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ]
life is full of unpredictable
movements and events i mean my girl was
mad at first because it was i'll give it
to her super tape there's debris flying
everywhere that guy gets hit by a car he
pops up she's like what if someone would
have me i'm like i know i said you're
that kind of guy that i do but i told
her i said would you have would you
rather be married to a guy who sees
those kids stranded and keeps [ __ ]
going i said look at all these [ __ ]
passing us right listen man i've said it
or when i parked the car there there's
like there's some
by the time i came back there's more
people gathered there and they go do you
think we should go over there and help
like
10 minutes ago you [ __ ] idiot what
have i told you from the day i met you
every time you
let your
your anger get in the way or something
what have i always said to you you're
that one dude you're you're i always
said you you that's your job that's
that's your job in one way or another to
set that example to be the prince and
and that's why i told joe like my girl i
said
you know you saw that guy whether he's i
don't know if he's trucker how he was
there so fast i if
i
probably assume he's the truck driver
i'm and i'm not too i'm so much bigger
and stronger than those people and most
99 of people that have pulled over so i
can make a difference i can ge i could
have got that door down yeah you can i
can break the window i can grab the kids
and pick them up i can't do all that you
know brennan
you're also a [ __ ] tough guy yes and
i'm not talking about physically yeah
i've said this i said this the other day
you are a natural fighter and i talked
to guys who you played football with and
the guy who played pro for eight years
he said the only reason brennan's not in
the nfl is he wasn't seen by the right
people and he said nobody could grind
and break your will like that dude and
you were that way when you fought you've
been fighting a lot of people don't know
about about your your your ufc career
but you know the guys that you were
competing against have been fighting for
10 15 years sure brennan really had
trained i think a little less than i
mean it was definitely less than two
years
and and might have been awesome
yeah yeah two years and and and then was
thrown into that with heavyweights where
if you get touched you get knocked out
so you've always been the kind of person
from from i've seen this recently this
year and everything else that you're
always you stand and fight you you
you're not a guy who shies from from
from the challenge so that is your role
and and and i i think that that's a very
important role to take and and you
should never escape from it yeah it's
risky yeah some bad [ __ ] could have
happened but again thank god you were
there and i guarantee those kids will
will see this someday and always be
indebted you saved their lives man yeah
you know
now i have a less heroic story but let's
lighten the mood a little bit shall we
can we lighten the mood a little bit
bravo
you did a great job you did a great job
and and and you'll have it's a great job
if we can raise money for those kids
this isn't about me being a badass it's
it's raising money for that family to
give those kids dude think about it you
so those kids you're the oldest they
said all under eight so the oldest one's
eight it's so there's so what eight six
four and probably two and you have no
mom or dad
so your your starting line is way back
there when everybody is else that's
right
it's just not it's just not fair and
they had nothing to do with it
unfortunately they got dealt the hands
of a shitty [ __ ] dad yes
so the only regret i have is seeing that
guy not knowing what a piece of [ __ ] he
is and not [ __ ] his world up man yeah
but then again that's the thing that
keeps me up his world was already [ __ ]
up he was willing to kill himself with
his family
so whatever's going on with that guy
whatever demons is going on with him he
wanted to take that despair and that
self-hatred he's he he hates himself
more than you could ever hit him he was
trying to kill himself so that's a guy
who whatever's going on with him he's
obviously completely out of his [ __ ]
mind and then and then beat the bomb
non-stop sure i'm sure didn't stop with
the mom i'm sure those kids saw
something i'm sure i'm sure so they were
freed from that but we'll do something
we'll we'll do some [ __ ] yeah we'll
figure it out yeah i reached out to that
aunt so hopefully i emailed her last
night so hopefully you'll hear back good
good yeah man i'm sorry you had to go
through that i'm sorry i'm sorry about
those kids
you know
um you think like all the [ __ ] you see
like the war movies you know i'm into
serial killer [ __ ] i've seen all the
docs and i read the book where you see
it
dude when you see it now when you see
those kids oh you know and i knew right
away as soon as he's like there's one
more and i'm holding the kid i look down
oh [ __ ]
well that's pizza get up get a blanket
and cover the [ __ ] mom dude yeah
you had the wherewithal to think that
way but you know that's ptsd man that's
that's you know sometimes it's helpful
to talk to people or
it's the first time i've been able to
tell the story and not
[ __ ] just break down
those [ __ ] kids man but that's worth
that that's worth breaking down over
some things in life is my i saw a
shooting and my friend i was depressed
for two weeks and my friend said hey
dude
some things in life bring you to your
knees and you're supposed to and they're
supposed to and you're supposed to lose
sleep over it you're supposed to if you
don't lose sleep over that and if that
doesn't [ __ ] you up then something's
wrong with you yeah
and and sometimes the only way out is
through and just to go through it and
feel it but now think about this
everyone wants to [ __ ] on cops and chp
and stuff like that they deal with that
every single [ __ ] day yeah so before
you want to [ __ ] on cops and to fund
them and do all that [ __ ] think about
what they deal with every day so you
don't have to deal with it so when
you're doing a hundred miles
when you when i told them about that
they're like
yeah we had a similar thing happen like
this has happened before like oh dude
we have stories that you don't want to
know
when i was like oh and i'm describing
what the mom looked like and all this
stuff going on like yeah yeah we've seen
way worse yeah there's a picture of a
fireman this this kid is terrified he's
the kid is three or four and parents got
all messed up and he was terrified
because the accident was good you know
the loud noise the kid's terrified and
you see this fireman this dude he's got
he's got a [ __ ] off and he's lying down
with the kid with happy feet the penguin
movie on his phone showing the kid and
just going look at this and just i mean
what a [ __ ] hero yeah so you're right
man they deal with they deal with that
[ __ ] you know
just that's why when they pull you over
and you've been doing 100 or you're
texting and they don't have anything
they don't have a sense of humor and
they're like you have no idea yeah
yeah man
i'm sorry buddy yeah i'm sorry about
that then i think about because i
stopped to get gas if i didn't stop me
gas i would have passed it i wouldn't
have seen it you know like there's all
this little thing i go through all of it
well
you were there that kid was probably
praying for something yeah he was
probably praying for someone like you
you know
yeah
what a [ __ ] what's your story brian
uh
let's talk about me guys because
this is about me
uh no my house got broken into in venice
yes my house got broken into
my neighbor walked by and he goes to
your garage and your gates open you know
i said why it's neighbor but but so i go
[ __ ] you know
and uh
so my house gets broken into did they
steal seven black shirts well
what's interesting
he goes he goes well it's really weird
because your your wrestling mat is laid
out and your weights
are all
kind of lined up maybe they get a little
workout in oh oh and then your bicycle
is on your treadmill
what and i go what and then he goes i'll
go inside and
liquid death that i got a bunch of those
there's like there's a tower of liquid
deaths and then on the on the toilet
is a bunch of books these books are
lined up neatly and then upstairs toilet
books and towels
and then on the laundry thing is like um
he took um
uh like little like gadgets like i don't
know like like whatever and made a cross
how do you know it's a he i don't you
sex as [ __ ] you're right i don't but
either way
this gentleman then took half my chairs
put them on top of oh you know what this
table is called a creepy crawly manson's
family used to do this is this true yeah
they go in and [ __ ] with everything just
to confuse you
uh-huh and then they come back and
murder you she had a very expensive
purse it was turned upside down but they
didn't take they didn't take nothing
nothing was taken
he just this person just did just put a
lot of weird [ __ ] everywhere just when i
admit to you that was me i thought
and that was my so i was so i'm looking
around it's called creepy crawling
anything that's been missing and no it
wasn't here yes you said manson family
creepy
they called it i don't [ __ ] call it
yeah you know cameras they call it a
creepy crawly i do now
yeah i didn't have the dogs there for
for only this weekend you have guns too
right i got guns
yeah so you have guns dogs problems
cameras but when you leave you don't
leave the dogs
the only
gave the dogs to to the ex when i when i
left yeah
that was the only thing that's some
german shepherd
shepard ain't letting any not to have
cameras in venice though are you out of
your mind yeah well especially that area
we made some we've made some changes
some big changes you gotta [ __ ] yeah you
got it because at least they didn't take
anything not a thing no let's be honest
what would they take
my flat screen dude my scooters yeah
there you go mike okay i mean not but
not much you know like my clothes you're
going you don't have like anything like
that
i don't have anything no they'd be like
you probably when i was like oh [ __ ]
just [ __ ] everything up there's
nothing to do yeah but it was no i think
it was just one person who was just
weird
yeah they called a creepy crawly to
scare you yeah
they come back and murder you oh so i
got to be ready i would be ready at all
times have you german shepherd
perked up i don't need that i'll be
ready
please
please come in with with the intention
of the only problem is pop is on the
road a lot and he got a post about it so
they know when you're gone
yeah you don't think about that yeah
yeah but i do have i do
i'm sorry that's so aggressive yeah i'm
sorry
i i was i
uh the lack of creativity
you don't think about that do you [ __ ]
fast oh i didn't hear the [ __ ] smart
i just heard you don't think about it i
know you didn't hear that
hey you don't think about it do you [ __ ]
face
but i heard the [ __ ] thing
i don't know i ran out of [ __ ]
faces aggressive
heavy over afghanistan oh last night
what's your dad's stance because bite
him completely [ __ ] over afghanistan
well i mean where's your dad on this
well my dad my i've oh you know how i've
been about
just the fact that we've been there for
20 years and you know as as as my friend
like tariq and people i know who afghani
and
you said they they tarik had been saying
forever i remember tar saying
we never had it in the first place
kabul was what we had but you know
afghanistan people always say when you
hear the press talk about afghanistan as
a country you're assuming the people of
afghanistan think of afghanistan
afghanistan is pashtun uzbek hassara
tajik all different tribes so their
loyalty is to their tribes first so this
idea of like this greater afghanistan is
a british kind of british invention okay
you know then an american idea or where
are you at with the uh
so my dad my dad my dad i i've been
critical of of the of the notion that
you can you can change the fabric of a
society that idea that we're we're going
to do this with our military and stuff
like that we've got definitely helped my
and there so there's one thing i would
say to any veteran out there who's
having a hard time right now and there
are people are there people that lost
their parts of their mind their limbs
loved ones their lives hiding the
taliban out there yes yes and there are
a lot of and we know them we know them
and there are a lot of men and women in
uniform who are probably having a very
hard time right now and they should be
they feel betrayed they feel like
everything they did and i can't imagine
what they're going through but i will
say this big but if you're somebody if
you're somebody in uniform uh at least
at least you guys gave them 20 years of
hope and 20 years of relative
freedom from that regime that's all i
can say then we just dip out ah you got
this and that's a bit and i have a huge
problem with the way that happened
however however i also think it's very
interesting that the entire country fell
in 11 days
and it's like without really a shot
fired what does that tell you what does
that tell you that they can't protect we
had an army that was 300 strong 300 000
strong and that army essentially they
were just mass desertions
so my feeling was that they they were
they never had allegiance they never had
allegiance to
the united states or to this notion of a
greater afghanistan or to kabul or to
the government that was put but they
also don't have the numbers to fight
back against the taliban
they did have the numbers and they had
an air force remember we created an air
force and an army it wasn't that they
didn't have that the question becomes
there are two things to ask when you're
in war what are you fighting against but
what are you fighting for
and i i don't i don't know that the
average person in the afghan army knew
what they were fighting for they had
allegiance to their tribes they had a
leader do you think they're better off
with the taliban at the
i would never say that because i don't
know enough i do know that the people on
the ground the people that i know who
are afghani who are talking which will
tell you this and i'm only going to say
this what you hear in the news is
probably a lot different than what's
actually going on in the ground good and
bad
okay that's all i know that's with
anything though yeah but then also did
you see the u.s embassy and then blowing
up americans flying away and did you see
the people just running holding onto the
plane and dying because they know
they're gonna die
because they know that they helped the
biggest problem the united states has is
that when these people who helped the
united states and helped that sort of
effort to modernize and build schools
and build hospitals and build electric
dams and build an army and build a
police force and all that work and all
that money and all that sacrifice from
the afghanis and the americans that were
there that went into that and and and
the one thing the biden administration
they'll say it's an intel failure and
everything else the one thing about
administration never thought would
happen and if you don't believe me
listen to a speech july 8th just
recently he said there's the we we are
the army we put in place is way stronger
than taliban they're 75 000 strong we
have 300 000 military uh
trained armies and he said and he said
we are gonna we're gonna extract
responsibly
and safely
there was no time
there was no time there was no time
everything fell that quickly oh dude
like i mean but that took it over but to
me that the president of afghanistan had
to flee the country because there were
large parts of that country that still
had no electricity there were large
parts of that country that still
suffered from
uh grinding poverty and i don't know if
you could fix it in 20 years yeah and
they're also not going to be loyal and
you're in jalalabad you're not going to
be loyal to kabul yeah
they're not one unit no no it's it's
the united states not the united africa
afghan people who know that country will
tell you to say it's a country is is a
western concept to the afghanis they are
again they're loyal to their tribe
they're pashto they're uzbek they're
huzzah i don't have enough uh
intelligent knowing what was the best
choice there i have an opinion on it but
it's not it's not like you know you talk
to some people who are involved in it
and they're they're like yeah we give
you a phone call i've been critical of
the whole effort because it's taken 20
years and all that money but i am very
hesitant to
i'm hesitant
i don't know if we were there another 20
years i don't know if it would have been
different i don't know there's only one
way to find out though sometimes you
know what's really hard to admit as an
american failure
not just that that maybe when there are
injustices and maybe when there is uh
terrible things going on in the country
maybe
despite our best wishes we can't do
anything about it maybe as americans we
have to learn that maybe as americans
that that that's a bitter pill to
swallow it is for me
because we've always been you know in
our minds the good policeman
but maybe that's naive yeah so i don't
know man
uh how's that do everyone's all
depressed
guy was just looking up in the distance
otherwise people wouldn't know what the
[ __ ] was going on the great thing about
this podcast is you know people say i
feel like i know you they do
they do
they go through it with you how's the
dating life kyle it's going okay you
know um it's tender uh so it's it's
tough and how often are we on tinder um
every time i get home from work you know
i get every night
is it swipe left to deny swipe right to
accept
yes yeah and you swipe in a lot of right
yeah just just rapid fire then pick and
choose from there now well take it easy
not a lot of matches though um not not a
ton it's it's here there's so many
there's so many fake profiles out here
that you just you can tell that they're
what's the point of a fake profile i
have no idea i don't know if they're
kind of like like catfish
it's all girls
yeah
the reason why i deleted my tinder was
because i noticed there would be smoke
shows and then you they like oh add me
on snap you add them on snap like hey
i'm selling a premium snapchat yeah it's
like spam yeah oh
so kyle do you have like the there's
like a tinder
you can yeah premium yeah
i don't i don't think i have that
because
yeah
is there a shot i can see you give yeah
like can we see yeah let's see is there
any shot i can see you just want to get
his dick wet yeah and also he does
you're a bit of fashionista you you kind
of you give me a hard time with the way
i dress can we bring it up on the big
screen chin if he sends it like if you
like screen shot or something would you
would you screenshot my photos or
whatever or if you can log into that
yeah what'd you say well i want to see
what he's wearing it might be they might
brennan could you know sometimes with
your outer layer can turn some heads
a necklace a scarf yeah a necklace or
something
like you're right you have a book like
oh you caught me there you go whoops
like scarf somebody likes to break a
mental sweat too some guys like a
stylish man i didn't realize how like
like how important like the way you look
in your pictures or what like your
pictures are when it comes to that it's
everything it's [ __ ] wild it's like
the fat chicks take pics like this
correct dude they can't take it on like
this
the larger girls swipe right
swipe left okay i sent him to chen
what we're working with and you're not
on there either christian not deleted
what are you using uh bumble bumble yeah
that's where the bubbles were they got
to talk to the girls got to mess with
you first yeah yeah
wait wait what did you say cow the
girl's got to message you first time i
said the hoes after that well first i'm
like well i don't want to yeah i want to
call him that
bumble
like lit right now like that's the thing
the young kids are using i mean bumble
hinge tinder all right i told you about
hinge though
good one right come on
so you know what
that's what jesus yeah hell yeah
dude i bet there's a lot of hot young
jewish ladies there yeah i wouldn't have
just
you might once like do too much only
farmers only i actually got onto this
latina app like it was meant for like uh
what's it called
chispa
what i think i saw it on snapchat i was
like [ __ ] it like it was like the
attitude you got on it yeah hell yeah
yeah a lot of different dating apps yeah
that's how people meet these days uh
there's one just for black that i'm on
too how'd you get on that
date your brother
i get i got more likes out than i did on
okay
using b okay okay he's just
bigger yeah i wanted to show him the
height like where i'm at height wise
that makes sense yeah what you better do
with the videographer
i was pretty fit at that time this uh
not that one that's a good picture yeah
it's you know this one with a nice
turtleneck it looks like 90 day fiance
yeah that that one's good that's a good
photo these aren't bad first of all yeah
they're you know why you do that
well you know just to show you likes
chicks yeah
okay that's my friend uh megan from ohio
well she's actually in austin now she's
a dude why can't i ditch she's in austin
texas now she moved to austin
i think she does have a man you're gonna
like her yeah
yeah she's a very pretty woman wow shout
out meg
black hair that's a good one good bottle
it bodies
you know what i do love a job
yeah financially sounds like i said wine
photography music movies brunch okay i'm
into all that [ __ ] and yeah and then
your caption says let's go get a drink
yeah it does now is this your lead pic
me and you as the lead picture yeah
that's the first one they said i would
take that off you look a little bit
prison gang mm-hmm kind of sexy but
a lot of people know brendan on on on
there so probably they watch the show
they
get them to be like oh who's this a lot
of girls are into stand-up comedy you
know so i like the one with the
turtleneck it's very very
european yeah that guy yeah roofie your
drink yeah yeah
yeah i would say
there it is that that's
a turtleneck and it's good color oh no
that's not cool
here's the problem you're you're kind of
you're kind of dark there and you're
pretty blue i'm pretty pale now yeah
yeah yeah those are solid pictures and
the one with you and the dog [ __ ]
love dogs yeah they do i didn't get to
bring her out here but kyle and they
they appreciate like like the iphone
photos more than like an uh like a
professional professional shy
with a glamorous shot now no you would
like i'm not a glamour guy yeah just
like you know my my these are better
than i thought though i appreciate that
i watched the girl swiping on i think it
was uh
what maybe it was not it was hinge yeah
i think good looking dudes
the guy the guys would like it looks
like they they they got a canoe and a
[ __ ] dog and they're out near a river
i'm like you shot this dude
who how the lighting is so perfect your
hair's in your eyes you like you know
it was like i want to marry that one
huh what's your profile he took it down
oh no but he's on a bunch of other ones
oh um it's just basic it just says uh
i said like horny yeah yeah you're
wearing it
shirt but yeah nah you show you had a
sense of humor they'll they'll see it
they're like ah
hey it worked it worked back home
i had one back home i worked at home
yeah so a girl started talking to you
based off of seeing that shirt yeah it
was that conversation started yep i see
what you did
but still
aggressive you know how uh the this
indians logos band right they got rid of
it so i got the hats like collectors
item you know i don't i just like the
logo and i i'm getting a gold sharpie
i'm painting the tooth gold like me and
jay had his kids i used to do it to mine
and jay's hats when we're kids
i was at the malibu car show cars and
coffee yesterday and uh a mean tiger
waiting to look at this car a 918 spider
it's like my favorite car ever
and i hear a guy behind me go that hat's
offensive
come on man ready he goes that hat's
offensive i'm like here we go i let grab
tiger and like stay close i try and go
oh and i look and he he has on the
indian's hat and he goes give it up
brother and he goes i wear it because it
offends people then i go me too dude
he's [ __ ] fist bump it was like an
older white guy like 600.
i love that stuff i sometimes i just saw
something that was so funny to me i
don't know if you guys think it's funny
ah sometimes you see something on
[ __ ] uh uh in the inter internet that
makes sense well you got this brian come
on got that yeah how many sentences are
you selling i want to see what you guys
sound like biden right now
he [ __ ] i do i do you know
[Laughter]
instagram it makes you laugh so hard i
want to see it it's very rare i didn't
disguise it i mean this guy's kind of a
genius he's young and i think he could
be a really good comic just based off of
this and i [ __ ] you guys if you don't
think so watch this
all right
this is funny it's gonna be terrible no
i don't think it's gonna be have an open
mind give him a chance
i just think that some people you can
see them do one thing and you go oh you
could you could do you could be really
funny outstanding
if he's not doing it i love him
and don't diss him because he's young
and i know he could be really yeah
you're the one that the funniest thing
unfortunately the funniest thing that
crap me up on the internet is the kevin
hart and don cheadle thing that's
probably where he goes on 56 yeah he
goes he goes me i'm 57 6 or 57 kevin
hart goes damn
and
though
but like don cheeto's like face like
he's just such a great actor but but
like they were having fun with each
other but such a nice person too oh you
met him i've not met him i've just said
i'm desperate like i just said hi yeah
[ __ ] a nice person
this is on tick tock yeah this is the
video you're too old for tick-tock me no
it was just it was somebody sent it to
me and i thought it was funny as [ __ ]
i think it's an nda
oh okay well thank you that's another
kid dropping the balloon i know i was
like what do you think it was that kid
dropped in the balloon
do you know which video bro yeah it's
the one with the moose oh i love this
guy oh hold on you know this guy yeah
he's [ __ ] hilarious
is that he's he's oh so he doesn't i got
to follow him yeah he does it all like
all the animals do you have a tick tock
brian no
that one video has 16 million views oh
he's [ __ ] okay so he's no wonder i'm
not the only one who thinks he's [ __ ]
i found this guy diamond in the rough
here everybody so talented wait he's
just like i was laughing it was like
it's hard to do this
there it is go up come on right there
right there right there we need to have
a series 21 million views
this picture pretty much started my tink
top career because the first animal
video ever made was dedicated to just
how ridiculous this actually is and what
was true a year ago is still true today
at seventeen hundred pounds to seven
feet at the shoulder the moose is always
gonna be one of those things god forgot
to put a scale limit on the average male
moose is 10 feet tall about the same
height as the basketball rim you
probably can't touch somehow this roid
deer is actually closer to size to an
elephant than an actual deer also moves
can swim and they'll dive up to 20 feet
in lakes just to eat underwater plants
which means at least once in the history
of mankind some guy actually lived this
and probably never slept well ever again
his therapist drives a bentley also
moves can run through six feet of snow
at 30 miles per hour those numbers might
not mean much to you but i bet this
video will it's not even the running
that scares me it's what the hell she
could possibly be running from and i
don't even know how to describe this
either the water's shallow or that's
moose christ it's the musaya you know
that thing where they say you should
never swerve to avoid hitting an animal
95 of the time that's because that five
percent is when this antler grim
reaper's on the road on a scale of one
your buck makes with weinstein if you
hit one since its entire body can come
down to your windshield and crush you
the moves might walk away but you're not
coming out of that without wings in a
halo this right here is why canadians
are polite landlords are moose and they
pay taxes to geese you'd be humble too
we need to have a serious talk moose
[Music]
no it's interesting for sure
it's got 21 million views
people do like it there's 21 million
views
like i laughed at it
that kid is going to be able to just
find it on youtube i don't know like
doing stand-up
videos
go to youtube and just type in kevin
hart
okay
that was listen to me
i like how he said he goes he goes [ __ ]
y'all if you don't like it
that's correct which one either i would
oh that's funny watch this
put me you know i'm 56 years old damn
i'm sorry
i can sit up here and honestly say buddy
that that was from a place of love got
it
like damn you didn't if we could play it
back right
these are two different damn
the rest of you doing talk shows ellen
all you cool i'm gonna do one better
he's so good yeah it's like one more
he's like real in depth he doesn't miss
he does nothing bad nothing he's so
funny
all right jim what do you got dude
let's take a little break from chatting
with the boys the kid and backflip lacy
because one thing about me it's well
documented kids i'm always on that
kratom i stay on kratom podcasts stand
up workouts i stay on kratom but just
not any kratom i use super specio
because the only one i can trust it
helps boost energy for some it relieves
stress enhances your mood i freaking
love it and super speciosa has only one
ingredient that's right it's pure kratom
leaf baby it's all good man i love
kratom it boosts my brain and god knows
i need all the brain power that i can
muster so i rely on kratom kratom is
used as pre-workout pro i
anything i do on my kratom chin two look
at him it looks fantastic 100
satisfaction guaranteed with super
specio or your money back try kratom and
get 20 off your entire order to and go
to getsuperleaf.com
fighter and use promo code fighter for
20 off your first order your entire
order all right again that's
getsuperleaf.com for 20 off your entire
order you know who loves restaurants
grubhub grubhub loves freaking
restaurants from the food to the passion
and determination of people behind them
they know that restaurants reputations
matter they'll be damned if that
reputation suffers because of them
because good food deserves good service
delivered fast fresh exactly how the
restaurant's intended to be restaurants
work hard to serve their customers and
grubhub works hard to serve them all
right
so what do you need man
you're building up an appetite you need
food grubhub got you covered grubhub got
you covered and today grubhub's doing a
little extra to serve panera panera brad
we love panera get free delivery perk on
your first order from panera of 15 or
more all right order through the grub
hub app or online grubhub we serve
restaurants all right first one
oh this we saw we thought oh we talked
about this on brian she's free
yeah britney spears told us about this
your dad agrees to step down as a
conservator
so does that mean she has free reign
over her life what does that mean
christian no one read the article
it's weird
anybody put a little work in
here this is the one that founded christ
uh so let's figure out on the show yeah
uh britney spears landed a huge winner
legal battle against her father
jamie uh
agreed to
so he's not doing it according prepare
for orderly transition new concert so
there's gonna be a new person that steps
in i don't think she's half oh
there are in fact no actual grounds for
spending or removing mr spears it's
highly debatable whether change in
conservator at this time would be best
in spears interest
do i feel like there's something going
on that we don't know about because
obviously if she still needs somebody to
look out for her best interest she's not
fully what is that about
so the dad went yeah i'm out man she's
mentally ill and she has an addiction
problem so all right have fun does she
have an addiction problem does she is
she mentally ill though do you think a
court would go through this severe i
don't know you know what i'm saying like
they would have to know they're
seeing things there's experts i'm sure
who are like yeah she obviously has some
issues and i don't think she's all there
but i also don't think her father
she's not all there i don't think her
father should have complete control the
worry would be something like like i
want to give all my money away right now
or something like the erratic behavior
or something
i don't know
so she has to have a new
conservatory
yeah so someone's going to step in i
wonder if she can i wonder yeah she's a
shame
i forget i remember in the documentary
she wanted someone from the banks to do
it to control it so she can't just go
nuts with her money she's like we'll
just have the bank control like give me
a certain amount and have someone like
uh
somebody from the bank control most of
it yeah but that's not what banks do or
would agree to no
so you have to have someone there's
there's
when people say that it's like but
hopefully there's a way something's
legal yeah hopefully she she can have
saying whoever it is
who has her best interest in mind that
would be almost like he's not going to
just jack all of her money like her dad
her because dad piece of [ __ ] make her
work and then not let her leave the
house and [ __ ] you know weird and that's
why she's my biggest thing is that she
she doesn't have her children which is
yeah that's what i was to say i was like
yeah what all does this
fail kevin federline like you don't see
him be like yeah free brittany like he's
not saying anything he's been quiet
yeah i think you're right i think i
think there's more to the story that
we're not getting and i think it's easy
for us to go free brittany and the
court's gone nah [ __ ] we can't right
yeah i agree there's a reason for it
it's gotta be around now i don't think
her father should have full power over i
think this is a good thing but hopefully
someone comes in with her best yeah
nothing at all i don't know the dad yeah
i just yeah i think you're you're
cautious you're cautious what's going on
there do you want to step in like this i
think you're you know usually you get
into the details people are not crazy
mean or nuts like if they're and for the
debt you know in california for the for
the dad to have full
power over the kids over the mom like
you know i'm telling you she's an adult
too like california always sides with
the mom right like something's going on
there dude yeah but i'm glad she at
least has some freedom now
yeah hopefully her instagram isn't as
[ __ ] weird what's what's the latest
thing she's she posting strange things
she's like i got an ipad
didn't she post a video of her like
burning her gym down like she was like
dancing and her gym was like burning
down
[Music]
alrighty
but yeah what's she post
this is the last one
he's in spanish yeah
that's really cool
all right she's showing us a rainbow
nobody gives a [ __ ]
well it's a full rainbow it's a nice
rainbow though
that is a [ __ ] thick
rainbow did i tell you about the elk
damn it no that wasn't her caption that
was someone's comment was that a comment
yeah yeah her caption was the little
caption was dresses yeah
she didn't post anything weird that's
stupid what else do we have
uh this woman apparently had tried to
eat it kfc stacked burger and tried to
open her mouth to fit it and now she has
five surgeries and twelve screw twelve
screws on the side of her
mouth like a
yeah like in one bite
isn't that the definition of a spazz oh
like
that's a very special then i saw
pictures here
dude how much look at that so far
when her jaw did like displace that must
have hurt so [ __ ] bad so whatever
draw unhinged she tried to open it and
eat it in one bite and of course
okay that's a that's yeah okay
kfc stacked is she trying to sue kfc i
don't know if she's super enough but she
just smooshed this yeah
this might not do whatever she couldn't
she would not be able to scroll down to
what's her quotes she had five
operations so she said
uh
she said i feel angry that this happened
but it can happen to anyone who opens
their mouth too wide i was healthy
before you kfc burger with no underlying
health issues uh tmj just came from
nowhere ad didn't though holly said she
hopes fast food restaurants reduce the
size of their burgers to prevent this
from happening no [ __ ] no [ __ ]
no no you should try you need him one
[ __ ] bite you [ __ ] idiot
yeah i mean i when i see a birthday cake
i don't try to
open my mouth
i kind of swallowed the t-bone steak and
like here we go
i don't try to swallow the steak i chew
and there's just certain things you have
to negotiate in your own mouth yeah if
you've had your own mouth for 34 years
you'd think that you would know the
limits of your own
[ __ ] yeah how did you have to open
your mouth that [ __ ] watch okay she
was like i'm sorry are you are you are
you are you a snake yeah can you open
your mouth like a snake yeah yeah you
unhinge your jaw oh you're a human and
you've had the same mouth for 34 years
that's why we have knives and forks you
[ __ ] idiot yeah so you can cut in
smaller bites so it fits in your mouth i
would never i'd be so embarrassed if
this happened to me i would never talk
about this i'd be like i got jumped by
six dudes
i would never say i was sandwiched
i never would kfc
i would straight up lie about how that
happened yeah i would never say if i was
the kfc pr team i'm like
stupid can you imagine i'd call you
around you're like how do you feel i'm
like you know stupid all right don't
tell me about it i uh i was like what
did you do brian i had five operations
18 i i
well you get what you deserve right you
go like this to me you give me the
finger and you say you snake
no i'm not a snake all right well
wow and then you call me a [ __ ] face
yeah
what else you got jen what a [ __ ]
idiot yeah that's [ __ ] uh portsmouth
ohio ohio
look we can all be sympathetic to holly
stevens no one should have to go through
life keep going like you scroll up
without the use of full essential party
part like joe i can understand about the
faith follower anyways
all right but let's start putting
restrictions let's not start putting
restrictions on our fast food because
one person mess themselves up maybe that
stuff will fly in great britain where
she's from but not here yeah how old did
you hear this kind of case that sandwich
looked fire though it does look good
what the [ __ ] on it i might have to
look at this
it's got hash browns in it too which i
love
damn that's ham yeah ham that's cheese
chicken and fried chicken like i'm not a
ham guy probably gonna get one after him
if i dislocate my drawers then i'm such
a ham guy you like him
i'm all in with good ham yeah yeah oh
honey
yeah honey roasted hey i saw that movie
pig with with with
nick's case i saw that movie
i'm gonna say and i've been alive a long
time and yeah i tend to exaggerate it's
the worst movie i've ever seen in my
[ __ ] that's what you get
because i watched the preview if you
told me i watched it oh i'm not watching
this oh and you went i thought it was
john wick with a pig where he goes and
gets revenge and [ __ ] everybody up
it's the worst movie i've ever seen in
my [ __ ] life you want me to tell you
you want to know how it goes i want the
work i don't care
uh he goes to look for his pig
and he's not a badass he's a he's a chef
who lives in a cabin and he doesn't do
anything he just goes to try to find his
pig finds the guy who took his pig does
he kill anybody and then and then
doesn't kill anyone doesn't punch anyone
and his pig's dead anyway and then he
just goes home what a waste of time it's
the worst movie that's it it's the worst
movie i've ever seen in my entire life
i want my [ __ ] money back i spend
four dollars
on rent i want my [ __ ]
you rinse it for real
wow and and the the rate you know the
the it got 94 from the critics on rotten
tomatoes
get that
uh the south park creators were able to
buy castles this is great news
oh that place they're successful
with south park owners oh dude i'm
telling you the number one problem was
food and they forced my mama to eat it
and we got kicked out
still the funniest thing what's crazy is
they they refuse to sell it and then
because you know south park the the boys
almost have a billion dollars right
everybody knows that billion dollars
yeah they're stupid rich a thousand
million dollars
themselves you want to make a thousand
wrench
so they're like hey caspanita we'll pay
this much like okay
it was a dump anyways that place sucked
dude i'm sure you get the cliff divers
which is fun so they'll buy it now and
they'll oh it's gonna be dude it's gonna
be the main attraction denver
yeah man that's incredible
and this is a fight that broke out
between a rams and chargers game i heard
about that and
cat says it's a thick fight let's see
let's take a look
i gotta feel that big guy gets [ __ ] up
imagine being this drunk and into
football no
they're not even playing the [ __ ]
game they're just [ __ ]
well it seems like it's like four on one
oh oh oh [ __ ]
what oh my god
pull him down pull him over pull him
over here we go oh damn
oh god man oh he lost his footing oh no
oh that guy's punching
come on man i hate those people throwing
beer oh poor homeboy he tried to fight
he didn't try to fight him yeah he did
yeah he swung at five dudes and one guy
has an old doctor's young yeah
they're so tired now where's security
yeah oh my god the other guy's crack
this is a thick ass fight yeah
hey he had him all at first he was like
that [ __ ] but then he got dealt with
he kept wrong yeah then he got he lost
his foot
wow
that's a lot of crack
in houston this weekend everybody what
else you got jen
uh this right here dr dre's daughter
apparently started her gofundme she's
trying to raise fifty thousand dollars
because she got cut off in 2020 when she
started doing interviews about her
strained relationship with her dad
she was like talking [ __ ] about her dad
strained relationships so yeah most
likely i wonder what happened there
but also i mean all right
and what we're supposed to do with this
yeah
i think gofundme campaigns for people in
desperate situations i'm in a desperate
situation
uh i really don't want to accept any
handouts okay i mean she's doing this to
[ __ ] with her dad too by the way no it
makes her dad look off yeah i mean this
is this is
interviews yeah yeah she's probably
she's probably a nightmare she's like oh
you're gonna cut me off i'm gonna do a
gofundme ah [ __ ] young mother of four
has been working a warehouse job to pay
fifty dollars an hour doing uber eats
she's living out her rental car and her
children are staying with friends god
damn it
hey dr dre
yep
a billion dollars hold on
just like with brittany
we don't have to be morphing through
this yeah yeah fair
is there any other info on her no
that's the full article i think there
might be cat sent this one cat synthetic
cat what he wants to do with this dude
[Laughter]
might be a lot more to this story yeah
because why would he not help out his
daughter yeah
there might be
explain kids are living with friends um
uh is dr homeless an exclusive daily
okay going down he hasn't seen her in 17
years
he hasn't said he hadn't she had
never seen each other in 17 years yeah
but he was still giving her money until
2020
by people imitating her
keep scrolling down
huh i figured out that's the shiniest
thing i've ever seen keep going down
uh producers the producers don't start
standard furniture but she has not
received any support for him 18 months
18 months
she's not spoken to her father in 18
years yeah so yeah it stopped in 2020
january
something must have happened she spoke
to she went bad over to the press yeah
that's her
well you go bad on dr dre man
all righty
i mean yeah i mean
i don't know someone's playing
basketball out there that's cool do you
know about this situation dennis shorter
yeah he really [ __ ] up he was uh he's
gonna get 84 million dollars to stay
with the lakers right you know i'ma test
and then he actually got picked up by
the celtics for like yeah like less than
10 million yeah yeah less than 10 really
really [ __ ] up what
turned out 84 million oh he turned down
the 84 million lakers i'm gonna test the
free the free agency market that okay
well here's five million shut your
[ __ ] boston
5.9 million there was something in the
streets about him not getting along with
lebron
oh hey listen lebron could [ __ ] my girl
and i would stay around
84 million dollars a lot of people don't
get along also
i'm going to navigate myself most people
get along with them no
really no
i mean he's got a superstar team now
and they have old guys
maybe they might do something no they
ain't touching uh brooklyn
how are the subjects usually like
how do they usually fare and would you
say how does how do the celtics usually
like fair in the nba they're good
they're good are they honest they're
really good i don't really fight
i'm [ __ ] good i'm watching the hard
knocks cowboys really good yeah it's
been one episode
yeah and um one thing i just noticed
like i don't know you can be a superstar
and every single play you have the risk
of [ __ ] yourself up every single
every single player are you just
realizing this it's just such a [ __ ]
nightmare though
like so much money
that's prescott professional sport yeah
but i mean
you're a quarterback there's so much
money riding on you and one [ __ ] up
that's why you paid the big bucks yeah
yeah my lat hurts you know who joe
burrow he was our first game of the
season i think for bingles well they
didn't have a good offensive line and
they still don't well no he no he played
like six or seven games he was balling
yeah and he got his knee blown out yeah
is there any word on tebow and whether
he made the team or his his first game
was preseason i think yesterday he
didn't he didn't play well he missed a
block
then the throne he passes his way though
he's fourth on the depth chart and they
don't have them playing special teams
which is a bad sign it is yeah if you
can make the squad he's not gonna be the
starting tight end so you can tru
special teams they don't have special
teams four string not looking great oh
wow gonna be tough you get cut
we'll see wouldn't he
wouldn't you have him on your team to
increase viewership
then i mean see nfl you know that i
don't know
what else you got jen
this right here oj had an interview with
the athletic oj simpson and he said he
doesn't want to hang out around la
because he's afraid i posted this said
this is fantastic
you say they don't come to l.a because
they don't know where the murder is at
they might be sitting next you never
know who you're sitting next to hey dude
just give it up we know you murdered him
just stop doing interviews his her
sister spoke out
yes she's probably like this guy's out
of his [ __ ] way he believes his own
lies she says something like that
yeah delusional
well it's weird he's still doing
interviews right
yeah i mean he's very entertaining when
he does talk so
i'm surprised he just don't want to like
hide out and just like he said i figured
eventually somebody would confess
something you know yeah dude we know you
know i had one suspect i told my lawyers
to look at i still think he might be
involved but i can't talk about it
lapd is like dude
how are you gonna keep running what like
you guys see the video where he was um i
think it was like 48 hours where he's
doing an interview with him and he told
the interviewer he's like oh i got a
surprise for you they open the door and
he has like i don't know if he had
anything in his hand but he like
pretended to like stab her or something
like that
it was hysterical he's crazy he's insane
yeah he's you know he was like doing
like the horse
like it was hysterical i was crying
um he's bank though chris that's his
pension from the nfl they can't touch it
this is a little older but the new host
of jeopardy is mike richards and he was
once the i guess he was a producer on
that he also hosted other shows too
there's two hosts though tim and a
female oh really yeah there's two hosts
okay but people are pissed at him and
here's my thing i don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
about jeopardy but um
but this is better than the dr dre one
so thank you cat but um
they're mad at him because he was the
producer so like hold up you picked the
new host but you're the guy who picks it
and you're the producer so people are
mad about that but he's actually pretty
good they said that with analytics to
show that when he did guest host for
jeopardy the ratings went up so oh so
these people like them before oh yeah
yeah
yeah it's him and a female though that's
the their two co-hosts
is the girl from me
blossom oh my ambiance oh
she's it is my ability she's so awesome
i worked with her i love her she's cool
she's a great person
you know she's
she's pretty good it's also jeopardy
she's funny as [ __ ] she's on that big
bang theory yeah show too funny like i i
did a tv show where we improv a fat
actress with her yeah
hilarious yeah like every tick-tock kid
yes
that kid's very special yes she was
holding she would crack me up every time
we do something she was [ __ ]
hilarious she had she lost her dog every
time she could on the door some new
thing as good as anybody i've ever
worked with she's been again she's tame
it forever for a minute yeah she's a new
host of a [ __ ]
jeopardy
when's the guy from [ __ ] wheel of
fortune and passed away
you know he makes the most money out of
all of them have you seen he makes like
20 million sure he does [ __ ] and vanna
white how old is the man of white now do
you know how many loads pat sajak's
dumped in vanna white over the years hey
dude come on don't say that first no
i don't know
why 97 years old well he's he doesn't
host it anymore though that'll work 74
for him
i know dude think about her job
swipe
swipe
crushing it i know you can keep all that
but yep
yeah we get pretty
pat sajak that's his job i used to see
him
just kind of hanging he makes so much
[ __ ] money
he makes so much money doing that
[ __ ] show yeah and then drew carey
does the prices right price is right i'd
rather take him down the back and shoot
me so pat's asia i'm going to do that i
auditioned for it i remember they
no i'm sorry they wanted me to audition
for the prices right
and they were talking about how i could
make six million dollars if i did i was
like let me tell you something
i'm just not motivated by that there's
no [ __ ] way that'll be me i don't
want my life i don't want to look back
on my life as i'm dying going i hosted a
game show
that book bubba i probably wouldn't have
but i mean i just still wasn't even you
weren't open to the audition i was not
open to the audition sir i'm not doing
that yeah even and wayne brady does uh
one of them too he doesn't i don't know
what i feel like you're just selling
your soul when you do that i said you
probably like it though they don't
though drew carey used to be a beast
comic dude like your he was a monster
monster steve harvey
he i'm pretty sure he loves family for
you he's still awesome but he kills it
on family feud i can't do that i mean as
much as anyone can kill it on family
fusion
he lights it up
i just can't do it man
are those
you make all the money in the world okay
i don't know who the [ __ ] still watches
them but yeah sure don't care sure
grandma yeah older people money's great
money's great but not no you're selling
your soul can't do it like you dude and
then also prices right is year-round you
gotta drive down they're like come on
down
312 000 an episode that's how much wait
how much is it 300 say jack makes yeah
every night dude i would show people to
their seats for that money personally
yeah of course you would but then you're
21 though
but yeah remember drew carey had a super
successful sitcom did you carry straight
care
yeah monster comic yeah to go from who's
mine is it anyway
it's easy money money who's lying was it
anyways he's crushing your life if
that's
wayne brady was blowing up and he's like
you know what i'll host [ __ ] whatever
he's doing
i think it [ __ ] you up man i think i
just i just think you just get
complacent you're just like you're a
gamer
you're you're retired no you're you're
you're out of here you're out like
that's what you do now that's what you
do
for a living in a suit that's what you
do we got mayor here 74 from michigan
her lifelong dream to be on prices right
come on down
get into me every day
every day
and then
it's groundhog i i could have grandma's
game
could it i would never you're right
you're right
a new car i personally know i really did
because i was offered when i didn't have
money i was offered a lot of money to do
something similar and i i said i can't
do it it's almost like a retirement
second one
yeah it's good money but you're you're
out
i had two really big opportunities to
that people like real ones and i was
like nope i'm out i couldn't do it my
agents were like but they did it i was
like
i just said
like who wants to be a miller would be
cool it's like real short oh yeah that
one's pretty yes you know if it's like
three months in a year we can have a
conversation right well rob derek shoots
i think he shoots for a month the entire
like multiple seasons and he's out wow
but he owns all of it yeah that's
different amazing you can still live as
well
that's a business man that dude's a
businessman
i was i was gonna have him on fire and
he goes is there are you doing any at
like one in the afternoon he's like i'm
in bed by eight dude i'm like dude we
started eight he's like and that's the
other thing i can't be in bed that early
like you know well no rob doesn't have
to be he just he's like don't stay up
late dude yeah your fights go on to like
you get done at like 10 11. yeah is he's
too late yeah all right
well when there's a 1pm fight i'll keep
you posted yeah
well i think we have the best job in the
world stand-up comedy
and podcasting's awesome too just
hanging out talking like this and then
stand up is there anything better than
stand-up really when you're writing and
coming up with new ideas and seeing it
work on stage i mean i love it
yeah
is that it
that could be it yeah yeah you got
another bad one huh
i don't know did you watch i'm guessing
you saw the podcast with queen tarantino
oh we talked to you didn't pay his mom
yeah so that's because his because his
mom when he's young said you're not
you're never going to make [ __ ] off
writing and he's like cool mom um and
then became the most successful director
of all time
it's weird he's still he's like i don't
pay for anything for mama because i told
her that day he was a kid and she was
like you're never gonna make him riding
quit wasting your [ __ ] time season
all right i'm not gonna buy your house
so i'm super successful she's like okay
now he's super successful he doesn't
give her any money that's holding a
grudge huh
she just loved him and was worried about
him maybe i don't know maybe but you'll
be careful with the way you talk to your
kids man yeah again we don't know the
story
all right that's it
i'm a fan of quentin tarantino i love
quinton you're a fan of mine
you come to houston this weekend that's
the third time you push it thursday
thursday move these [ __ ] tickets dude
let's move these tickets guys brian.com
or tfac
fhkz.com where are you going to be
brennan uh i'm not in north carolina
anymore because of delta and the
hurricane we had to reschedule but you
got [ __ ] you got cancelled because
god's god was like here's a person
here's pestilence and the perfect storm
i said god i like it i don't mind taking
a little break from the road uh-huh
cause i'm gonna do shows at the haha in
los angeles and i can still sleep in my
bed so this friday and saturday two
shows friday two shows saturday
chappelle lacey
david lucas and myself will be at the
haha two shows friday two show saturday
tickets will be up uh by the time this
comes out they should be up all right we
learned i just signed on to do the shows
today so that will be available at the
hot in los angeles this friday and
saturday and then next week my favorite
club in all of the world the comedy
store at la jolla california thursday
friday saturday august 26-28
me and the crew will be out there right
outside san diego one show thursday
right now we might add a show thursday
two shows friday two shows saturday then
san jose california september 9th
through the 11th then the big boy san
antonio bud light event center one show
september 24th that's a friday one show
september 25th that's a saturday get
your tickets at fatkz.com
this stick boy t you guys have seen me
wearing on the fighting pin and on here
it's a collab with built and that will
drop uh in a few weeks i'll keep going
crumbs on your shoulder i know i was
eating before this
crumbs daddy crumbs daddy uh august 26th
bring an improv september 8th cobb's
comedy club october 7th through the
night tampa florida sidesplitters i
don't need to go all the way down chad
yeah please don't go through 2023.
he's like in november of 2023 i where am
i at
give me something to do in [ __ ]
houston you like that town what where
where'd you go stuff uh we'll figure it
out dude what's up restaurants and stuff
that barbecue yeah that's right barbecue
what's it called true truth all right
true i know the owners they took us in
the back and everything that [ __ ] though
i don't and it's so hot in houston right
now oh
i don't know what hot has to do with it
see what the temperature is in houston
right now yeah
when you eat the barbecue what's your
guess hold on uh [ __ ] uh they have
hercules i'm saying 93.98 i'm saying
i'll say 98. really that's [ __ ] hot
let me see here houston
82. lightroom that's right now was the
was going to be the high today what's it
what's it this weekend um 88. oh oh
never touches 90.
yeah well there it is nine two with that
humidity though that's gonna be oh it's
gonna be it's gonna be a lot of fun it's
not terrible though but that's nothing
with you eating barbecue though you know
no because i get it because that's just
you and i yeah
yeah yeah yeah i have trouble with it i
get it i get what you try that hot
chicken in nashville uh how'd you do
which spot did you go to which one you
go to though the famous place
that's the most famous yeah it was
something like that it's not that hot
there's hot owls out here nashville will
kill your old ass yeah kill it hey that
other one we ate in nashville that
second one prince something like that
was chicken that wasn't uh that wasn't
sandwiches just oh yeah because we did
chicken tenders and we went for the the
hottest thing they had
all right kids were out of here all
right